So, in an effort to add more fuel to the
Charlie-is-secretly-an-old-man fire,
I've spent the last week here in the Canary Islands,
specifically on Gran Canaria where the majority
of the other holiday goers here are
at least 30 years older than Emily and I.
I didn't plan for it, but I have found myself
on a holiday for old people.
These guys have absolutely no interest in going
"wild" on vacation, and,
kind of unsurprisingly, I'm very happy to be a part
of this crowd.
In fact, sometimes the people here actually seem
younger than we do.
On our first night here, everybody was dancing by
the pool to an Elvis impersonator
while we were off to bed at 10 PM complaining
about the noise.
Almost all of my time here, so far, has been spent eating,
reading, and napping, and it has been great.
I would've spent more time exploring the island,
but honestly it seems as though this place has
been built specifically for eating, reading,
and napping.
In spite of not doing much exploring here, though,
I have found a number of other things to marvel at.
Mainly the breasts.
There are a lot of breasts out in the open here.
In fact, I'm pretty comfortable saying that the
amount of breasts,
real-life breasts, I've seen in my lifetime has
quadrupled over the course of the last seven days.
Also, this is the point in the travel vlog where I
would show you a montage
of all of those breasts, but I'm not going to put you
through that, don't worry.
I haven't been recording them. Obviously.
Now while eating out all the time has obviously
been super lovely,
one thing that hasn't been so nice is that,
for some reason, every single place to eat here
has a man outside it yelling at you,
telling you to come and eat at
his restaurant right this moment. I mean, I guess it's
a tactic that must have work at least
once on somebody because now everybody does it
just in case it works again.
You can never let them down right away either
because they always start with a question like,
"Hey. Do you like eating?"
I mean, yes, yes I do, but not with you.
"Hey. Where are you from?"
I'll tell you where I'm not from. Hungry.
I wish I'd said that to them, but I wasn't
brave enough.
Now we have ended up doing one big activity while
here called AstroGC, which was awesome.
A man came to pick us up in his van, took us to the top
of a mountain at nighttime, and we went stargazing.
The high mountains and the lack of light pollution here
mean that Gran Canaria is just really good for stargazing,
and so, thanks to that, me and Emily can now say
that we have seen Jupiter
and its moons, the remnants of a supernova,
the Orion Nebula,
two star clusters, and two galaxies.
And not only was it an amazing experience that I
won't ever forget, but it also makes me quite happy
that I have seen something slightly more
spectacular than just a lot of breasts on this trip.
Anyway, this is the bit where I'm meant to relate the
galaxies in the sky to
the breasts that I've seen on this trip and turn
it into some lovely
metaphor about loving yourself and you're a star,
but honestly I can't be bothered.
I'm on holiday, so I'm not gonna. Adios, amigos.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Thank you very much for watching. Here are my past
two videos. One's about sex, one's about Britain.
If you can guess which one is which, you'll be in
with the chance of winning
the grand prize of watching one of these two videos.
Oooh. Ahhh.
I'll leave the rest up to you. Goodbye.
SILENCE